increasingly urgent push to get more
americans to please
do their part to prevent a surge of
unnecessary the word is
unnecessary covades this fall president
biden is expected to announce later
today that for the first time
all federal workers must get vaccinated
or follow very strict protocols
also mask will now be required for
everybody including visitors
inside federal buildings and covet hot
spots that lines up with the new cdc
guidance advising people to wear masks
indoors
in high transmission areas even if
you've been vaccinated
nancy cordes is at the white house with
more on this story nancy good morning to
you do you think this could have an
effect on the private sector as well
no question gail that this will set a
precedent for states and cities and
companies across the country because
what we're talking about here
is the entire federal workforce about
two million people
from coast to coast plus contractors who
would
all be required to either show proof of
vaccination
or submit to regular testing now this
would actually be
a little less restrictive than the
policy that facebook and google
announced yesterday both of those tech
giants say
all of their employees who come to work
in person will have
to be vaccinated period unless they
can't for medical reasons
now this all comes on the heels of new
guidance from the cdc
recommending that even vaccinated people
return to wearing masks
indoors in the many parts of the country
where covered cases are on the rise
interestingly white house officials say
that yesterday they saw the highest
number of new vaccinations
all month more than 750 000 doses
nationwide a sign perhaps that news of
these impending restrictions
and fears of the delta variant are
causing at least a few more people gail
to go ahead and get their shots or fears
of i don't want to die nancy before you
go can we talk about the
this major new deal on the
infrastructure so there's been months of
negotiations
we're now hearing that 550 with a b deal
550 billion dollars worth of new
spending over five years
so what happens next how's this going to
work so
this brand new deal passed a very major
hurdle
last night when two-thirds of the senate
a bipartisan group of senators
voted to begin consideration of the bill
and that is a very good
sign this is a deal between the white
house democrats and republicans in the
senate it would sink
an extra 110 billion dollars into roads
bridges and other major projects
it would pour about the same amount into
rail and public transit
plus billions more for broadband
airports drinking water
and the electrical grid a good chunk
of this new plan would be paid for with
unspent covid funds and unemployment
funds but this bill is still being
written
gail we've got weeks to go before a
final vote
in the senate so still a lot to watch
in this view well we know you're there
thank you very much nancy